ich beurteile gerade dein telefon und
modellen speichergröße den grundzustand
ungeschützt mit eur er nicht lang und
vorne hier auch noch das heißt wenn ich
jetzt runter fallen lasse das ist kein
reiner hey leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
hier auf meinem hauptkanal er arbeite
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich muss
erstmal sagen dieses video ist praktisch
ein zufalls video
man wollte es so dass es so passiert
kann man eigentlich so sagen ja kurze
vorgeschichte und wahrscheinlich auch
schon der sound ist besser
das liegt daran weil ich jetzt nur noch
so micro ihr gekauft habe für meinen
neuen zweiten kanal denn hier unbedingt
abonnieren sollte da kommt auch jeden
tag video verlege ich euch in der video
beschreibung auf jeden fall von meiner
freundin marie sie ist gestern irgendwie
die treppe runter gerannt und ihre
handys runtergefallen also ist einfach
sie hatten iphone 7
was eigentlich noch top funktioniert hat
so ist runtergefallen gegen erstmal
nicht an
da war natürlich das geschrei groß weil
in der heutigen zeit wenn man mit dem
handy auf werks brauchen wir noch eins
irgendwann ging es dann zum glück wieder
an
allerdings funktioniert bis jetzt die
home taste nicht also dieses ding was
man eigentlich braucht hier unten und
sie ist dann zu dem entschluss gekommen
sich heute morgen ein neues hinzukaufen
iphone 11 glaube ich und ihr altes handy
dann im besten fall dagegen
einzutauschen und dann noch ein bisschen
rabatt zu kriegen so das war der plan
dann sind wir zum apple store gefahren
weil ich habe das halt bei mir auch
schon immer gedacht so wenn mein handy
irgendwann mal kaputt geht dann tausche
ich es einfach ein und kriegt dafür noch
ein bisschen geld
wir sind dann zum apple store gefahren
und haben ihr das iphone halt besorgt
und auch bisschen somit den gelabert und
jemand ein
normalerweise nehmen wir handys gerne an
allerdings wenn ich nicht mehr richtig
funktionieren sprich home button ist
kaputt tasten an der seite lauter leiser
geht nicht mehr dann muss man die erst
mal reparieren lassen und das wird in
dem fall wahrscheinlich schon über 180
euro kosten bei dem iphone 7 oder 150
euro
und das lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht
dann kannst du dir auch gleich da machst
du ja verlust wenn es dann danach wieder
verkauft so die meinten für das gerät im
jetzigen zustand maximal noch 70 euro
ich habe das auch alles aufgenommen
so
wir sind gerade im apple store mal
rücksicht neues iphone 4 ist halbwegs
kaputt gegangen ist und jetzt überlegt
ob ich mir auch ein neues
ja leute und dann ist mir die idee
gekommen
marie pass auf wir versuchen jetzt mal
wenn die uns maximal gut sagen wir mal
die hätten uns dafür 60 euro geben
wir versuchen jetzt mal dein handy in
diesen mediamarkt automaten zu stecken
falls ja immer noch funktioniert weil
das war ziemlich in der nähe sag ich mal
und dann habe ich halt einfach so ein
bisschen mitgefilmt und ich versuche ich
das so ein bisschen zusammen zu
schneiden
weil es ist wirklich sehr sehr
beeindruckt was da am ende raus kam
wir halten mal kurz fest hier noch
ausschnitte aus meinen letzten beiden
mediamarkt handy automaten videos oder
[Musik]
verkaufe ist jetzt an bord unter anderem
mit ihr machen geschenkkarte
träger 33 euro ich glaube auch wie krank
ist das dann halt einfach 120 euro
wertverlust
ich habe damals meinen voll
funktionsfähiges iphone 7 plus in den
automaten gesteckt haben 165 euro
angezeigt bekommen
ein guter preis im internet würde ich es
nicht unbedingt für mehr verkaufen
können
dann habe ich ein samsung alpha 20 oder
so ich weiß nicht genau wie es hieß für
200 euro bei saturn gekauft und es
direkt danach in diesen automaten
gesteckt mir wurden 33 euro angeboten
und dann fand ich jetzt einfach nur
interessant zu checken was wird marie
für dieses handy angeboten was sie macht
ist also ich will das noch nicht zu viel
verraten aber das angebot ist schon ganz
heiß so obwohl halt diese tasten kaputt
und ich habe keine ahnung ob der automat
ist überhaupt gecheckt hat ihr könnt ihr
eure vermutung in die kommentare
schreiben aber ich war echt sehr
überrascht und das seht ihr jetzt
sondern ich will das jetzt mal hier mit
meinem handy werden gerade für marin
neues iphone gekauft
hier ist sozusagen kaputtgegangen ist
das ist gestern runtergefallen da ist ja
home-button kaputt wenn wir dieses
geschrei und jetzt hat sie hier ein
neues iphone 11 in weiß wirklich so
sieht schön aus
ich habe als ich letztes mal so ein
karton in der hand hatte ist schon echt
sehr sehr lange her
ich bräuchte eigentlich auch ein neues
handy weil ich das ja auch praktisch
beruflich nutzen
warum sehr sehr coole bilder aus
genau weil wir fliegen am freitag nach
new york zum aller ersten mal
und hier ist jetzt ihr altes iphone
iphone 7 und das problem ist hier der
home button ist kaputt habe ich
wahrscheinlich auch schon erklärt und
wir wollen das jetzt noch verkaufen bei
media markt weil da war ich ja schon mal
bei diesem handy automaten und ich habe
gesagt nein das ist mir den ganzen tag
ich will aber trotzdem wissen ob star
weil die bei apple wollten uns dafür 70
euro geben was ich sogar verstehen kann
ich weiß gar nicht auf erden gesagt wenn
überhaupt 70 euro werden und ich bin
jetzt mal gespannt ob dieser mediamarkt
automat ich glaube mein iphone 7 + hatte
der 165 euro bezahlt mal gucken wie viel
er dafür bezahlt und ob er erkennt dass
der automat überhaupt funktioniert weil
letzte mal war der kaputt ob der erkennt
dass der home-button defektes und es
dann runter stück vom preis weil sonst
würde ich sagen du kriegst für safe 340
euro
das immer nicht verkaufen muss wir sind
noch alle meine daten auch nicht
verkaufen
hey ich bewege mich das zu machen
ich kann den zustand des telefons
angeboten telefon dabei ja wenn man zwar
zu verkaufen
wenn du mehr als funktionell sein
telefon länder und in welchem zustand
ist natürlich ein bürger leicht
abgenutzt
august ist ja dass der hund stationiert
sein musst du dir deine telefon auf
mit entfernten nicht sogar einen
aufkleber aus mit denen ich dein telefon
wieder mit karten folge auf die
aufkleber rückseite der apa welcher typ
ist zu seinem theater ich werde mich
stehen damit ein
sein display gesperrt ist auf dem spiel
das ist der beste teil ich hoffe dass
jetzt nicht entfernt werden damit der
betroffene mensch wäre das disco waren
ein du kriegst erstmal angebot und der
beherzten ausschließen
da kommen wir gehen zurück unsere
scanner gehen
ich beurteile gerade dein telefon und
modell speichergröße features und
zustand unterschätzen
mit anton zurückgeben und so erhitzter
indikatoren jederzeit jeder bissen
zahlungsvorgang sondern schon 450 alle
daten geklaut
ja wahrscheinlich alleine in deutschland
spannung sehen wir
ja leute was geht ab herzlich willkommen
zurück das ist das mikrofon da muss hier
rein sprechen also ihr habt ja gesehen
wir haben für dieses handy hier nochmal
ich habe es eben nicht ich habe es ihm
nicht zur hand der home button geht
nicht ja der ist kaputt und
normalerweise sondern die was defekt ist
apple hat gesagt höchstens 70 euro auch
noch nicht mehr sozial
auch im internet wird man so was
garantiert nicht für 105 euro los glaube
ich nicht und deswegen ist das angebot
doch ich würde heute schon gefragt ob
ihm sein 450 euro ja sie ist und
deswegen würde ich sagen 105 euro ist
schon krass also ich habe jetzt die
erfahrung gemacht für iphones lohnt sich
diese automatik die immer komischer
weise ich weiß nicht ob der gecheckt hat
dass der home-button nicht geht
aber ist ja egal solange wenn du das
geld habe ich nicht das weiß ich nicht
wir können ja mal schauen aber wenn du
verkaufst du da jetzt gab das nicht
warum nicht kannst du mit löchern haben
okay aber interessant also media markt
auch schon mal hat lohnt sich
anscheinend ein bisschen mehr als dann
tatsächlich bei apple oder oder es halt
irgendwo anders zu verkaufen im internet
ebay kleinanzeigen
also man erspart sich damit wirklich
stress ist praktisch schon fast wären
video hier aber ich kriege dafür kein
geld leute reinbringen
das ist ein gutes mikrofon ja danke fürs
zuschauen abonniert den kanal abonniert
auch auf jeden fall meinen neuen kanal
alex v
da gibt es jeden tag um 30 und richtig
neues video und wir sehen uns hier dann
übermorgen wieder mit dem neuen video
sei und wir sagen nein sagen wir einmal
ein neues handy sogar ganz wichtig hier
mit dingen space und vorne hier auch
noch das heißt wenn ich jetzt runter
fallen lasse das ist wenn ich's darunter
fallen lasse überlebt es noch leute haut
rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]